hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be answering
your specific property investment
questions i've been investing in
property now for over 12
years i've done hundreds of property
deals and this is your chance to fire
away any questions that you might have
and i will do my very best to answer
your questions to help you in your
property journey to financial freedom so
let's see what questions we got from
last week also
don't forget smash the like button also
if you're not subscribed please
subscribe to the channel and turn the
notification bell on that way you won't
miss my response video to your questions
so get commenting your questions below
while i'm answering other people's
questions if you have an offshoot of a
question that just pops into your head
go ahead fire away comment below let's
see what we got so shanna sampson says
i have a question that i don't believe
has been asked
when you buy a house and you're getting
home insurance do you get building
insurance and content insurance with the
cover or just building insurance which
covers the bricks and mortar as i
understand you have an option and you
don't have to have both also understand
contents covers what's inside the house
such as clothes etc
shana thank you for your question so
yeah if you're buy if you're buying a
house and it's your house and you're
going to live in the house and you've
got lots of computers and tvs and things
expensive clothes not that i would have
expensive clothes or even expensive
things in my house it's pretty bland but
you might want to get contents insurance
insurance um just regular building
insurance uh is something that is as
you've said that kind of it covers you
in case there's a fire or there's
anything that happens with the house if
you're buying a property to rent out
generally speaking you're not going to
get contents insurance because it hasn't
got stuff in there that belongs to you
it belongs to the tenants however
regular building insurance is a
you've got to do it it's not a what's
the word it's mandatory it's not it's
mandatory it's compulsory it's the same
as car insurance if you have a car you
have to be insured in the same way with
property you have to have insurance
typically generally speaking for like a
three bed terrorist house that you might
rent out you're probably going to pay
about 20 pounds per month for building
insurance so it's not expensive but it
is compulsory i hope that helps all
right next zachm
says what is
the best way not one of the ways what is
the best way
to get capital
personal loans
finance company loans etc
zach um it really depends on what the
loan is for like if a personal loan for
instance if you're trying to get finance
to buy a house to rent out you can't get
a personal loan because if
if you're getting a mortgage on the
property like a standard buy to let
mortgage the mortgage lender is going to
ask you where your deposits come from
and if you say oh it's a personal loan
they're going to say well we don't want
to give you a mortgage because you've
got no skin in the game it's 100
financed
so
our personal loans good yes you can do
lots of amazing things with personal
loans uh bridging loans are bridging
loans good it depends on what the deal
is a bridging loan
is usually a
expensive
but it'll bridge the gap between buying
a property and then refinancing it so to
say what's the best way to get capital i
mean listen if you've not got much money
and you're looking to
raise finance to buy property because
you've not got much money at all
yourself i would probably say rather
than trying to raise capital why don't
you go make some money
why don't you go and
package some deals and sell them and get
paid
and then it's yours and then when you've
got money you can then borrow money
against the money that you have and
start really leveraging what you have
you know so it depends it depends it
depends it depends i hope that helps zak
sorry if it doesn't uh next audacious a
b c
says
can you talk about rent to rent also
landlords giving their property to rent
to renters and how to find
them
audacious abc if you want to find the
it's not about finding the landlords
that's the easy bit
in fact it's not even about getting a
rent to rent that's the easy bit
because finding the landlords come on
man they're everywhere
you can just you can just go on
openrent.co.uk
and every single property that you see
is
direct to landlord you know gumtree.com
and just type in flats available in
birmingham or wherever your city is and
there's going to be loads of flats
apartments houses for rent direct to
landlord with the person's number adam
call adam 07456 blah blah blah like
how do you find
landlords come on man
it's easy
how do you even get rent to rent it's
easy
you just contact them and say to them
i'm looking to rent your property on a
corporate let can i book a view in it's
easy the hard bit
is actually
adding value to the property so that you
can profit namely turning an apartment
into a service department namely turning
a
a student a shabby student let where the
landlords just missed the boat and now
he can't get tenants and converting that
into a professional house share and
pushing the rents up that's the hard bit
but you need to be able to get landlords
they're everywhere you just got to be
able to speak to them okay i hope that
helps abc audacious abc i love you so
much audacious abc i've got an audacious
outrageous love for audacious abc so
audacious abc if you're watching this
video you better like it twice you
better go set up a different account and
like it twice um all right jb says hi
samuel my question i have a mortgage in
principle as a first-time homebuyer up
to the amount of 2 300 sorry 238 000
good
with 15 which is which my family will
provide look at you good do you have any
advice on how i can leverage the
position i'm in to make the most of it
and get closer to financial freedom well
firstly the fact that you've got a
decision in principle and you you need
15 deposit reminder said that some
lenders won't give you the money if the
deposit's not yours because there's no
skill in the game guess what if the
deposit is coming from your family we
call that a gifted deposit a gifted
deposit means that the lender's gonna be
happy and they'll still lend to you it's
amazing but it has to be gifted from
family member so that's all good um so
if you're buying a house to live in
the only way you're gonna get
financially get close to financial
freedom by living in a house is if you
buy a house to live in but then rent out
one or two of the rooms
to lodges
man i've got so many students doing this
buying a house on a residential mortgage
renting out one of the rooms to a lodger
the money that you get will be tax free
as long as it's up to 7 000 pounds a
year
that's crazy an extra seven grand a year
just for renting out a room tax-free
spend it how you will damn you should
probably spend it on some of my courses
tax-free and then the courses are a tax
write-off boom shakalaka so that's what
i'd probably suggest jay if you don't
want to do that though if you're like oh
man i don't want to rent out one of the
rooms i just want to live in privacy and
all that then just rent somewhere for
the time being maybe and and then use
the money ask your parents not to give
you money to buy a house to live in ask
them if you can take the money to invest
it in a business
okay
show abe hussein
yes showaib who's saying he says just
wanting to do some due diligence on
bradford
all right
what are some nice areas with reasonable
prices
and what are some bad areas you would
suggest not to buy or invest in
i'm wondering do you mean what are the
good parts and bad parts of bradford or
are you just asking me generally now
good areas and bad areas um if you're
asking generally where's a good place to
invest where's a nice area where can you
get good rent my answer would be every
single city has good areas and bad areas
okay you're always going to have the
rough parts and the nice parts unless
you're like me and you live in beckons
field then you just got the nice parts
baby but no i'm kind of kidding even
beckonsfield nah becca's field is just
nice but generally speaking you've got
nice areas bad areas within an area so
bradford for example
i'm trying to think of the nice parts of
bradford um
what i would suggest you do
is i would suggest you
firstly work out who's your demographic
are you going to be doing hmos is it
going to be students is it going to be
professionals are you looking to do dss
housing housing associations are you
looking to buy and rent out to families
single their homes firstly what's your
demographic because really it doesn't
matter if the area is nice or average or
not nice or it doesn't really matter
because
if your demographic is you're renting to
housing associations and those housing
associations are looking for ex prisoner
offenders you don't want a nice area
anyway so who's your market who's your
demographic
and then when you know your demographic
then speak to some agents in the area
and say hey this is my demographic what
about someone looking you know you don't
want to be buying a house on benefit
street and renting out trying to rent
out to a family because it's going to
happen but if your market is dss tenants
that are on benefits if that's your
market
then great then buy a house on benefit
street
last question and i'm going to answer
this one the best okay i'm going to put
my most
energy into this question
this is from burning desire
my heart burns for you burning desire
hey samuel if i was to go into a joint
venture with someone how would i protect
myself
is it by getting a contract written by a
solicitor and then get them to sign it
also create a limited company with
percentage slips of ownership thanks
this will help a lot
this my last question burning desire if
you're doing a joint venture how do you
protect yourself firstly
you've got to work out if you're doing a
joint venture you've got two parties
each party needs to bring equal equal
value to the table okay if i'm doing a
joint venture with you i'm gonna say
right
i'll put the money in i've got a hundred
grand what are you going to put in
you can't say i'm going to put the money
in as well because then our roles are
the same our roles need to be different
i'm putting the money in what are you
putting in you could say i'm putting in
the time and the and the energy and i'll
put the deal to the table
i'll manage it i'll go cool
let's do a deal
what we're then going to do is we're
going to set up a company between me and
you now there's there's about nine
different ways you can do a joint
venture of course you're going to need
solicitor agreements every time you do
one but the standard way is this
we're going to set up a company burning
desire
and samuel leads limited okay that's the
company i'm then going to loan my money
to the company as a director's loan the
company is going to buy the house
add the value refinance it rent it out
whatever
and then
once it's refinanced and the company's
got its money back
i'm then going to get my money back
and then any profits
we're going to split 50 50. that's
generally how it's structured so
of course you need a solicitor involved
um you need to do it properly man people
trying to pitch me joint ventures all
day they're like saying i'm going to
join venture i'm like even if i said yes
you wouldn't know what to do next
because you are so uneducated and your
deals suck and that's why it's so
important to get trained and that's why
i am running the property investors
crash course me personally okay if you
want to come and meet me and get trained
at the property investors crash course
guess what it is free that's ridiculous
why would i run a free training program
i don't know i'm kind of crazy like that
i want to see you succeed so i'm gonna
leave a link in the description get
booked on come meet me
people say but samuel it's too far i
don't want to go down all the way to
nottingham or birmingham or whatever
just make the trip okay because if
you're stoppable
when the first hurdle comes
ah i can't come to the crash course
because it's a two hour commute then
you're not gonna succeed anyway you're
gonna be stoppable every step of the way
so get down to the nearest one in your
house i'll leave a link in the
description do it do it now i look
forward to seeing you i look forward to
working with you and i look forward to
helping you win thanks so much peace out
god bless